yeah silly white boy's got a question
here says let's get that box that's his
name by the way yeah uh
let's get that box open ken have you
gotten into tcg like pokemon and yugioh
if so what's your opinion on them sure
so first of all as a personal collector
i do not personally collect tcg however
my eight-year-old son paul is a big
pokemon collector
i also for those of you who follow me
know that i have broken pokemon cards
with logan paul and um you know i'm
friendly with him and logan is actually
an investor in golden
so i recognize and he's a huge he's the
biggest pokemon guy out there he wore at
wrestlemania two nights ago put the
picture up he wore this cartoon
in fact that's why that that card is not
on here that's the list is also outdated
because he paid 5.275 million dollars
for that pokemon card right there you
see a psa 10. yep and he paid 5.27 mil
what makes that card so special it's um
so what it is it was a special
promotional card of pikachu one of the
most loved characters like he's
designing the pokemon cards it's called
called the illustrator
there are only i think there are less
than 40 that are known making it in
theory rarer than a t206 owner's wagoner
although it was made a hundred years
after um so it is a modern card but it
is it is basically the honest wagner of
all pokemon cards and this is my
viewpoint on pokemon on tcg
um and it's also my viewpoint on comic
books um which i think is really a a a
blossoming investment for you know for
collectibles
baseball is really a u.s sport you can
say you know asian sport as well but you
know you go and go to go go to the
street and ask a kid do they know who
roberto clemente is do they know who
willie mays is a lot of them won't um
ask a kid if they know who joe montana
is they're not going to um ask a kid if
they know who charizard is pikachu is
batman superman spider-man wolverine
they're going to know and it's going
global what a point so you have
you you have a worldwide population i
don't know how many people in the world
right now is it five billion eight
billion eight billion jesus escapes so
eight billion you have access to the
entire world where they know these
characters whether it's the tcg
characters like the pokemon or yu-gi-oh
you know or the especially the marvel
and the dc characters i mean marvel is
part of disney now so
years from now people are going to say
oh my god
wolverine actually had a comic book
spider-man had a comic book and i can
own the the creation of that or i can
own a action comics number one the first
ever superman or a detective 27 first
batman or batman number one so i think
that i really like all of those areas
long term
based on the fact that it has
you know a constant replenishing of the
potential people who might be interested
in buying that product if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]